it's time for screen junkies movie
fights this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile America's best unlimited
network
oh hi Internet what it's movie fights
we're back and we are rejuvenated
revamped reconfigured kind of like
matrix were reloaded no no yeah you
didn't like that matrix we're gonna be
better than Matrix Reloaded you guys I'm
Hal Rudnick and I'll be hosting today
and we're excited to be back um changes
are afoot you guys sent in a lot of
thoughts we read them and guess what we
implemented many of them
sorry stoner 69 we didn't inter we
didn't use that one that you sent anyway
uh we're introducing a new way to play
the game they're going to be three
rounds and four speed round questions
we'll get into that but there are three
judges deciding each question okay
they're gonna be three boats to each
answer and let's meet our judges
first she is holding it down checking
the facts and figures looking stuff up
maybe doing some googling Roth cornet
I'm here I'm ready to Google I've Google
open while Google is available to us yes
yes net neutrality Roth glad you're here
to see Star Wars yet I did oh there's a
review on screen oh yes let's check it
out of course you know what I subscribe
I am a screen junkies subscriber and
guess what your voice is going to be
heard we are going to listen to you and
incorporate you as one of the votes and
to break down how that works
it's our social media chairwoman Daniel
Radford hello so you guys know we have
always had polls but now your votes in
the polls mean points for your fighter
so if you click that little white eye on
the upper right hand corner of the video
when the topics come up there will be a
poll that appears vote in that poll
because your poll met your vote in the
poll matters and whoever wins the poll
will get a point towards the round if
you are confused click down in
description down below we will spell
everything out for you I promise
Parise thanks Danielle I couldn't have
said it better myself I hope that makes
sense for everybody you can vote on
YouTube and yeah that's awesome the
audience gets to vote well it's pretty
sick and I'm gonna be here as your judge
and host and if there's any tie from
over there I'll break it oh yeah I
accept that responsibility and you know
what what you say we meet our fighters
you guys so in 2018 we're going to start
a new start fresh all records out the
window I'm kind of glad about that
because I had a lot of losses movie
fights I had a really crap record but
what better way to close that chapter
than to bring in the two fighters the
only two fighters to ever hold the movie
fights championship belts first he is a
former movie fights champion he's the
producer of honest trailers Dan Merle
how I'm so happy to be here so I do
movie fighting again I'm happy to be
here with these people and having to be
back on the show this is gonna be a lot
of fun heck yes and his opponent he's
the head writer of honest trailers and
the the the belt holder of movie fights
oh man Spencer Gilbert ooh I I picked
the wrong time to have to poop so I'm
looking forward to a quick victory
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up you got a turtle sniffing
cotton also acceptable big brown dog
barking at the back door
what a bad way to start the show with
all of these poop euphemism Detroit's
poop boom isms okay alright so like we
said we got a couple of new rules first
guess what there's only two [ __ ] you
saw it there's not gonna be a mystery
fighter that pops up in the middle or
will there be no there won't be maybe
we'll incorporate that down the line two
fighters movie fights is now a
best-of-seven game just like your NBA
Finals is your world series is okay
best-of-seven they're going to be three
regular questions that they will debate
and then we go to the four questions
speed round the first fighter to get
four answer to get four questions
awarded to them wins there you have it
first one to four wins so it can be
three Oh going to the speed around and
someone could stage a massive comeback
yeah makes sense you guys yeah ready you
ready I'm ready to do this out ladies
you ready more than ready ready I'm
alright I'm warming down seat jte roll
that sick ass fight montage
[Music]
I love montages come on you gotta click
like just for that montage all right
first question how's it doozy right out
the gate what is the best superhero
movie of 2017 best superhero movie of
2017 and we are going to start off with
Dan Moreau
this is a great question there are a lot
that to consider I would argue that
there are I don't think there was any
one superhero movie that completely
disappointed me from top to bottom at
all they came out this year it was
between two for me is between Logan and
Wonder Woman and I went with Logan I
just think that when you look at the
superhero genre you can kind of rate
movies inside of that genre I think
Logan was the one when I looked at it
this year that I could write regardless
of genre regardless of like how does it
stack up against prior films or similar
films Logan is a movie I think that you
can watch having not seen an x-men movie
having not seen a comput movie and
appreciate on a human level on a
character level on just the pure
filmmaking level it is the one that has
stuck with me the longest as far as the
link going back and thinking about it
and thinking about just the plot the
story that the direction that the story
took and I think it's important when you
have you're in an era where a lot of
these superhero movies are good you're
looking for ones that surprise you
ones that actually make you feel
something ones that stand out above the
pack and are just great movies and out
of all the really good choices this year
Logan was the one for me that stood
ahead of the pack
alright strong opening round salvo from
Dan Morrell Spencer Gilbert what do you
got you know I like Logan I thought was
a great film great performances it was
refreshing to see the violence that does
Wolverine justice but when I picked
Logan I lost the coin toss so I'm going
with the second what I first thought was
the second best but now I think is the
best I'll tell you why Logan's garbage
later my favorite superhero movie of the
year was Thor Ragnarok this is a real
superhero movie this isn't a movie
that's ashamed so ashamed to be a
superhero movie it calls itself Logan
this is one that's hilarious it's
uniquely visually stunning this is a
movie that's in the MCU
that doesn't feel like an MCU movie this
feels like a taiko ytt movie they let
the filmmaker do his thing this adds
depth to a character that was kind of
two-dimensional before underneath all
the comedy which by the way again it's
funny and underneath the comedy there's
some real consequences and some real
stakes it's why it's my favorite movie
there you have it and Spencer pulling
back the curtain to show us that there's
a coin toss involved and all that kind
of stuff
gentlemen let's fight I mean if Spencer
wants to pull the curtain back there
Yuki this is perfectly I think that
helps my argument to be quite frank but
here are my thoughts on thor ragnarok
I'm not gonna sit here and say the thor
ragnarok derp that's a bad yeah I didn't
think so writer actor it's a bad movie
yeah I enjoyed it but thor ragnarok to
me felt like a really enjoyable episode
of a TV series that I've been watching
for the last ten years which is the MCU
I feel like you know it was fun it was
it was funny but it's not something that
has stuck with me after I left you know
I got a few laughs I think that in
service of those laughs they discarded
some of the things about the character
that they did like they discarded his
friends who were a very integral part of
his personality just very casually in
this movie with really no ramifications
there's some there's a very major big
event that I in case someone hasn't seen
they're not gonna spoil but there's a
life-changing event for that character
that I thought was undercut immediately
by humor I had some issues with thor
ragnarok that made me just kind of chart
it down it's like it's another enjoyable
Marvel movie which is fine there have
been three this year Logan is one that I
thought about after I came out not in
terms of where does it stand in the
x-men franchise but in terms of like I
can't believe they took this character
that I thought I knew and that I'd seen
in six or seven other x-men movies and
made me look at him in a different way
and Professor Xavier Patrick Stewart a
performance that is probably gonna be
overlooked for Oscar but is a
legitimately Oscar worthy move
performance in a comic book movie this
is a movie that doesn't just have to
stand amongst its peers it's a movie
that stands above them I think that what
they did and taking the chance with
Logan was to say we are going to
challenge what you think a comic book
movie can be we're gonna challenge those
conventions we're gonna take it further
than maybe you thought it could be
and I think they succeeded it was a risk
that succeeded you know it was a risk
but it wasn't this is a movie that
swapped one set of conventions for a
different set of conventions this Logan
is a bold x-men movie but as a movie
it's completely full of tropes and
cliches how many films have we seen
where the grizzled old hitman meets the
innocent young child and finds one last
chance at redemption
that's Terminator 2 that's the
professional that's the movie that they
watch in Logan Shayne with the little
kid in the cowboy come back Shane come
back Shane yeah this is a if you strip
away you can take the superhero stuff
out of it and what you're left with is a
pretty clichéd story trope and story
structure now in regards to them Thor
not having the weight not having the
gravitas can we spoil throw at this
point we can talk about cuz do you
brought it up and you brought up
Ragnarok the Despoiler alert if you
haven't seen Thor Ragnarok yes they
destroy all of Asgard that's a huge
dramatic choice and that was a really
interesting tack to say you know what
Asgard this place that Thor has been
fighting for his whole life
is actually an empire built on blood and
pillaging and to scratch away the
surface of that whole mythos me like you
know what where Thor comes from is
actually an evil place that needs
reckoning with and to choose to just
blow that up and turn everyone into
refugees is super strong and then yes
they do kill off the warriors three
right is that I dare you to name them
beyond lady SIF who who didn't die so
who are the Warriors three again Robin
Hood the other guy and Gimli is that
really their send-off got the the same
amount of gravitas that their entrance
had which was nothing like goodbye
what it did was it also introduced newer
better friends for Thor like Hulk who
the addition of a voice in his Hulk form
gives his character a whole new
dimension the relationship between Thor
and Loki reached a different stage where
Loki's learning that his old tricks
aren't gonna work anymore with him and
it won't get him the attention that he
craves and the introduction of Valkyrie
is just awesome it you think it's gonna
be the standard strong female badass
stereotype but its undercut with like
her drunkenness and her just attitude I
they added better friends than Thor had
in the first two movies I totally didn't
see that twist coming with Loki where he
was friendly to Thor and then he
betrayed them oh my god Thor saw two
yeah but that's the same things like
they're operating inside the same
confines of a movie and again like what
did you have you thought about thor
ragnarok once since you left the theater
and the things that you're saying like
Oh Asgard is an evil place that needed
to be torn down and you watch it you
know get destroyed in dismantled you're
right that would have been great if that
had been treated was any kind of
gravitas of the min tree with any kind
of solemnity or sincerity but it wasn't
it was a throwaway it literally happened
in the last 10 they made a joke about it
while it was happening and then they
didn't make a joke about it Korg made a
joke that any major character is to make
inappropriate jokes at inappropriate
times I thought it was hilarious he's
the he's the same guy that's saying like
Oh every day there's another Doug that's
part of his characters he says the
inappropriate thing during the serious
moment but humor in a moment that's
supposed to be serious you're telling
the audience that what they're seeing
isn't that important and that's what it
did it completely undercut that moment
and you don't see him deal with that in
any way shape or form it's in the last
five minutes of the movie and it's like
oh well whatever here comes Santos and
then the movie's over again I'm not
saying throw an arc is a bad movie but
it's a fun movie with a bunch of jokes
makhmur qing of comedy as an art form it
calling it a bunch of jokes do you know
how hard it is to make people laugh for
two hours Dan it's not easy it's a lot
easier to just give them the misery porn
of logan of like cancer all right
question which of these movies is more
rewatchable
i know that's not the question but made
a lot of factor which is more
rewatchable Thor Ragnarok you can pause
Thor Ragnarok at any moment and just you
can watch it again with the sound off
and just appreciate the amount of visual
splendor that he's crammed into this
whole movie you can watch it again for
humor sake for background jokes that you
made a mist and you can watch it again
because it's a great story and it won't
bum you out for the rest of your day
Logan is a hundred percent more
rewatchable comedies as much as I love
comedies once you have once you know the
jokes it's declining returns every time
you watch them and you're saying that
Logan is just another cliche movie the
movies that you named it's like what
other what other movies have this story
Terminator to the professional shame
those are three of the best movies made
in those eras and the reason that Logan
works is because it uses the framework
of that classic story which is a great
story and it's one it's not what the
story is about it's how you tell it and
Logan tells the story so much this about
responsibility about learning how to to
cope with your own actions dealing with
your own path these are universal themes
and that's what makes every watch
because you can relate to it it's not
just I'm not saying it's not hard to
make a comedy but drama and comedy are
two different things
and I think that what Logan did Marvel
makes we just saw it three funny couple
movies a year they just did it this year
they're gonna do it next year what Logan
did was to take the x-men franchise
something that people have given up on
something that people said can't go
anywhere else they turned it on its head
and they made it into something special
they made it into something relevant and
they made it into something that
affected people in a way that no other
movie in that franchise had done before
I like Thor but it is part of a system
and a machine that knows how to pump
things out but there's a ceiling to it
and I think you saw that in Thor Ragnar
I disagree I think that Thor is a unique
movie even in the context of the MCU
it's a teiko ITT movie that holds its
own tone and holds its own character in
a way where Edgar Wright and Joss Whedon
crumbled before the MCU filtered Tycho
ITT stood and stuck his flag in the
ground and it's still a great movie now
Logan I'll get I'll give it to you it
was heading that direction it's a great
set up things seem to be moving and this
is kind of subdued a really grounded
direction and then the second half of
that movie it undercuts it by going full
comic-book you get three completely
bland villains worse than right up there
with the blandest of the Marvel blue
aliens where you get the the evil
Stryker mutants or bad guy you have the
clone one the clone clone gun and you
have the the introduction of the the X
kids you know and Daphne's great but you
have like stick boy and cold breath and
stuff like that they answer this
question but they're not the important
things that's not what the movie is them
trying to run to Canada okay if I have a
whole thing about Canada alright I want
you to tell me if your movie was to be
nominated for any Oscars what Oscars
would your movie be nominated for let's
do hmm well visual effects is a given
director Taika Waititi and let's do
original screenplay great dan I think
you could plausibly label argue for
obviously Best Supporting Actor for
Patrick Stewart I think that you could
probably get a Best Cinematography
nomination from this I think he could
probably get Best Adapted Screenplay if
you're gonna say that it was adapted
from old man Logan because I thought
that was a great adaptation of that I
think that Daphne Keane was great I
think he could push for her for Best
Supporting Actress
I think the Hugh Jackman was great you
could push for him for lead actor I
thought it was one of my favorite movies
of the year I think you could
legitimately push it for Best Picture
BAM right up there okay uh gentlemen
what let me just ask both of you what
makes a good superhero movie in general
Hatton how does your movie fit that well
I think a good superhero movie is
something aspirational where you're
seeing somebody that that is held above
and refuses to compromise and it's
actually us and the characters around
them to go through the change and learn
from the hero and you can see that in
Valkyries arc she actually as the
strongest art in the film and in Loki's
art where Thor Thor is Thor's goals we
hope want to beat Thor and it's
something you go away smiling and you go
away rooting for him it's it's not this
new trend it's not the Zack Snyder
superhero model where depth is confused
with violence or misery it's it's a
positive movie positive message
something you leave the theater cheering
and I think that's Thor Ragnarok in a
nutshell Dan Logan does not confuse
violence with misery this is a movie
that is starkly anti-violent that shows
you what kind of damage being a violent
person your entire life can wreak havoc
oh that's why that climax is the steroid
rampage he goes on that's like the
coolest thing in the movie know that
again that is him using his last energy
reserves and that's showing the fact
that he's willing to become the monster
that he thought he had turned his back
on in order to save what he'd now
considered to be his family you're
missing the entire point of the movie
your versus the entire arc of his
character in this movie this is not a
movie that they can that confuses
violence with depth this is a movie that
is transcending what superheroes are and
saying that it's openly sneering at
comic books and saying like this isn't
real what's real is is the consequences
of what you have to live to it shines a
different light on superheroes it's not
just another one that's superheroes
fighting each other in a big arena and
laughs and jokes like that again I'm not
saying that's bad but you get three of
those a year this is one that looks at
the other side of that what
the consequences how do you have to pay
for what you do how does being part of
that team affect you if you lose that
team there's so many different sides of
it that you see and if you thought that
my movie was so bad then why did you
openly say that it was the second that I
thought arguments on both sides Spencer
why don't you go into your final
thoughts yeah look you say that we get
three of these movies a year we don't
get three great comedies a year we got
this and girls trip I don't know what
else what else was a great
feature-length comedy that's the drama d
um we do get movies like Logan every
year their Oscar bait their movies that
like Winter's Bone and stuff like that
where they're just they're just dragging
you through a downer place and you're
like oh this must be good because it
said I think that as Jack Lemmon said
dying is easy comedy is hard and the
fact that thor ragnarok works as a drama
and on top of that has an amazing
comedic sense of itself great
performance out of unfunny person Chris
Hemsworth sorry but no one that
good-looking can be funny the fact that
they pull that off make it my favorite
superhero movie all right Dan final
thoughts Sims worth performances and
many other movies and this is not the
first funny performance that Chris
Hemsworth has had he's an extremely
funny guy he's a talented funny actor so
I take offense on that first of all
that's not true secondly sure we can
wave we get more than two comedies a
year to say that this is better just
because it's one of a few good comedies
a year that you get that's also simply
not true and again you're kind of
putting that artsy fartsy hat on and
saying like oh nothing that's dreary
could be good and enjoyable i slog your
way through this one you can laugh your
way through mine I disagree
fundamentally with that and I think that
if you're gonna ask me what's the best
movie it's the one that affected me
emotionally and this movie affected me
emotionally
I think Thor Ragnarok blew through the
paces of trying to affect me emotionally
but I felt like it was too tied to its
comic-book origins to what the MCU was
trying to do and the tone that it wasn't
able to do it where the Logan had the
freedom to do it and that's why it
transcends the comic book tag and became
a great movie for me wow man
what a fight Roth can you believe it
[Applause]
I I'm loving this debate I am warming
Dan's chair like I said he will normally
be here so I'm feeling the
responsibility I want to shout out to
lon
just helping me keep an eye on the facts
as I listen to you guys and I got to say
some really good arguments warriors
three Hogan and if I'm mispronouncing
this I apologize Fandral and Volstagg
cloggin is x24 and some films some
comedies that people enjoy this year
include disaster artist
Ingrid goes west Lady Bird whispering
with my colleagues something about dying
is easy and comedy is hard
oh is that Olivier no one really knows
who did that quote we don't know yes so
comedy is very difficult and finding out
who made quotes is even harder yes I
have to say at first I thought you
really undercut it Spencer by conceding
the point to Dan in the beginning of
your argument by saying that locum was
the best in your mind but then you came
back strong by breaking down the tropes
but Dan sort of answered that by saying
it was using that framework beautifully
so it's really back and forth the entire
time but I think that ultimately and
despite coming in with a weaker argument
Spencer won the day based on the
arguments alright that's 104 Spencer
let's go to Danielle Radford on the
socials
alright well first of all a lot of
people are bummed that Wonder Woman was
not in this they are but they are also
bummed that transformers 5 was not in
this and the Power Rangers the movie
with so take it with a grain of salt go
ahead and just just a bucket it's not
all the same idiot is it different
people what did you put a little bit of
salt and a cookie it makes it taste
better so from the poll that we have if
you guys clicked up in that thing you
found it right now we've got Logan
leading at 65% and thor ragnarok at 34%
so the point on this is gonna go to Dan
Wow so that means we are all locked up
at 1:1 it comes to me to help with the
decision and yeah I I do agree that
Spence
undercut himself a little bit by
admitting that he thought Logan was the
best film but then he came out swinging
with especially I love the fact that you
pointed out Taika Waititi was able to
put his voice out there in this film but
I think Dan really rebutted that well
and pointing out that Marvel that they
have three good movies a year usually
and comedy is not unique to just this
Marvel film and dance points about how
this movie's unique commentary on
violence and superheroes and where it
stands in the superhero genre it really
struck a chord so I'm giving point to
Dan and Dan takes round one hard-fought
all right fellas time for round two they
still work on the graphics yeah there we
go
pitch a non superhero Disney Foxx
crossover movie so we know huge merger
happening we want you guys to take two
properties one Disney one Foxx and pitch
the crossover we're gonna start with
Spencer alright so one of my favorite
Disney movie was the last few years
Zootopia it's a movie that deals with
some real serious [ __ ] curse with some
serious talent it's a kids movie but
it's about racial profiling it's about
government corruption and it still
manages to be really super cute and fun
now Fox owns a flagging franchise called
die hard and that is a franchise that
needs something completely different
or it needs a different audience let's
say so let's cross it over with Zootopia
into a kids movie but still have it deal
with that real stuff with police
violence with income inequality but
let's do it in a really cute way with a
plotline that's built around Judy Hopps
what's the fox's name Hopsin Nick yeah
and and Bruce Willis's character Phan
McClane
yeah there it is Wow
so Fon McClain is is Judy Hopps new boss
he's a trigger-happy cop and they're
trapped in a hostage situation I tried
to draw another one I didn't really have
time for a hans gruper hans gruper takes
over the building a grouper fish yeah
and they have to shoot their way out and
this like seemingly fun die hard intro
but it's all caught on body cam so it
discredits the cops it causes a stampede
in town there if they're angry about
police violence and and it turned out to
there's a whole subplot about mass
incarceration I can get into if you
really want to do that but Zootopia was
this metaphor for contemporary urban
society that happened to be a Disney
movie so let's do the same with Zootopia
- in diehard Wow some heavy themes in
the Tokyo lunch is about crackers about
so many things yeah all right Dan what
do you got another revitalization of
what I believe are to flagging
franchises that might not seem to fit
together when you think about it and
this is Pirates of the Caribbean and
predator a strange fit when you think
about it however this actually fits into
predator lore if you remember at the end
of predator 2 Danny Glover gets handed
this flintlock pistol that says Rafael a
daleney 1715 on it the predator hands it
to him it's has taken and then
disappears if you do the research there
is actually a book called predator 1718
that tells the story of this pistol and
that is that and I'm not making this up
I have an illustration from this comic
we're gonna fold this into the Disney
mythology in the 7 and 17 18 wrought
raphael Adaline II who was a pirate
captain was venturing to find treasure
they found it in a church and he told
his crew you're not gonna take this
treasure out of the church so the first
part of this is Raphael Adaline II and
his pirate crew of venturing far north
of the Caribbean to Bermuda to find this
treasure
the crew is is spreading across this
mysterious island when suddenly the
triangle-shaped target appears boom
there go two of his crewmates they
finally do after his crew is picked off
one by one they find this treasure this
is good tying back to the original story
this treasure is in a church it's a
property this old mission
and the pirate captain I don't lean he
says you're not taking that treasure and
the crew says yes we are and the crew
mutinies against him and is about to
kill him when the predator jumps in and
fights with the prior captain against
his crew completely disarming this
mutiny at the very end the pirate
captain is shot by the last mutineer and
gives the pistol to the predator as a
sign of respect which is how he got it
which is how he gave it to Danny Glover
you're gonna tie this into the Pirates
of the Caribbean trilogy and the way
that I'm gonna tie this into the current
day is that years later this pirate
captains journals are found and the
pirate tale begins to circulate don't go
northeast be aware of the Bermuda
Triangle because that's how you
disappear the Predators and the triangle
target is where the whole legend of the
Bermuda Triangle comes from and it ties
beautifully into the Pirates of the
Caribbean mythology as we know it man 2
movies I really want to see fellas slug
it out I don't know man you started off
your pitch with if you remember the end
of predator 2 so already you've lost 98%
of your audience and you just pitched a
Pirates of Caribbean movie without
Johnny Depp I know you're damned if you
do damned if you don't but like what you
more heavily won than the other but go
ahead yeah well people don't want to see
Johnny Depp anymore but if you do
another pirates movie and don't explain
Jack Sparrow or where he went like what
the hell are you selling a ticket to how
are you gonna sell take it to a movie
where pirates and the Predators fight
each other that's exactly the movie
you're selling so you just said people
don't listen to Johnny Depp anymore
you're right they don't okay so it's the
predator and okay is this an art why are
you acting all flustered by my pitch
when you just pitched a non animated
character being in he's fawn McClane
he's right so first of all this nightie
that it's voiced by Bruce Willis making
a mockery oh great there's nothing that
I want to hear more than imagine how
checked out Bruce Willis is in his
live-action performance exactly well
that's nominees had a voice exactly he
is checked out in live action and yes
the die hard franchise has become a joke
which is why you bring it in to a kids
movie you give it new life by giving it
to a new audience making it a toning
down the jokes for PG die hard has
already ruined itself
Zootopia is still manages to do
kid-friendly movies that handle serious
topics the worst
thing that diehard did in the last
decade and that's saying a lot is toning
itself down for pg-13 well it's all the
damage has already been done our movie
you have any turn stuff down even
further now to a PG you're making a
mockery of a franchise that used to be
great I'm trying to revitalize two
franchises by adding elements from each
that's gonna make the other one better
you're just resigning yourself not only
are you you throwing the die hard
franchise into the grave but you're
adding a complication to a Zootopia
franchise that doesn't need it this
Willis is lazy voice over I want Judy
Hopps and Nick I don't want old man fawn
McClane hopping in there like yeah
what's going on kids you get my peach
kid and Plus hans gruber you're gonna
ruin the worst I mean the best villain
and the history like gods Gruber is the
one thing about die hard that they have
it ruined and now you want to ruin that
too
well okay you you're talking about a
franchise the two of your franchise that
discards everything people like about
them I'm taking items that people like
about die hard items people like about
Zootopia and combining them you've
thrown out the whole part of the
predator where the predator hunts people
you throwing out the part where he's
hunting the entire crew in the aisle
he's fighting back to back like um
gardening what I was I guess I did fall
asleep so they there's a you is it
r-rated is this a family movie this it
could be r-rated yeah come on man you're
not making a Pirates of the care of a
predator movie that's anything less than
an hour right we'll have to see where
the material takes it so you're making a
it's ridiculous this is this movie makes
this movie is for no one and no this
movies for everybody's alienated fans of
Pirates who are children who still like
Johnny Depp who still think it's funny
which is a diminishing crowd and then
people who are still invested in the
predator also a demand crowd you've
you're you're making a movie that
pleases no one at least mine is
something new for kids that would give
adults something to think about who
topia was in a movie that was new for
kids that'll give adults something to
think about that's why you don't need to
add some ridiculous Vaughn McClane
parody of a die hard character like that
is a hack that is like a hacky be like
like I want to try to rip off diehard
and I'm gonna like
nudge it in the ribs by saying like oh
look here comes fawn McClane
guys look at this terrible die hard
reference it's the classic Disney Pixar
the adults get every chance our
dimension crowd has to bring in I want
Union I want you to go ahead and cast
some of the Pirates who would you like
to see as pirates if there's no Johnny
Depp in this movie well I mean really
Raphael Adelina is the one guy that you
have to do he's the pirate captain I
think you get somebody badass you bring
in somebody like I mean if you want to
go of like older gryzzl you get it like
Anna tonio Banderas in there to really
like you know just bring a lot to that
role and then if you have a predator I
mean that's really I have a predator
which is I have one thing this movie
doesn't have which is the predator which
is a pretty damn good Banderas and a
predator grouper rather than a predator
who would do the voice of Hans grouper
Doug Jones Doug Jones the actor not the
sentence he sound like Alan Rickman he
can do a good fish though
all right gentlemen here you pitched a
predator movie in broad daylight at sea
there's nothing less scary about a
predator in the sunshine I've never been
hunted on an island by a predator so go
have that happen to you in the telling
me that's not scary I hope that never
happens to you Spencer okay I'm gonna
ask each of you to give us a dramatic
monologue from your movie Dan we'll
start with you and I want it to be the
pirate talking to the predator saying
it's a monologue about how he never knew
a predator could be his best friend
comedian now okay fine no model I guess
no place in my movie he'd become doesn't
he become friends it's a Disney movie
Dan it's gonna have a strong friendship
moments not anymore it doesn't it's a
new era Spencer okay how about the
pirate thanking the predator not how the
movies gonna be that heartfelt
conversations between a pirate and a
predator that's the kind of ridiculous
thing that Spencer would say was in my
movie that's not all right Spencer Dan
choose to pet Joe's to pass on the
monologue I'm gonna ask you to give us a
hans gruper monologue revealing his mad
stureplan you thought I was taking over
yucca Tomy Plaza just just to create the
hostage situation but actually it was to
cause a stampede that would fund my
network of private prisons Wow during
you know forget Doug Jones I think you
might be up for trying to get under
water but still German British
definitely caught an underwater vibe
alright gentlemen let's go to final
thoughts dan Merle I'm you're literally
making a mockery of one of the best
action movies of all time and and and
adding an element that no one no one in
the die-hard wheelhouse wants to see
this movie fold it into a kids animated
film despite what Spencer says he's
right when he says that the fans of
pirates of the carribean are a
diminishing crowd they've had enough of
the Jack Captain Jack Sparrow buffoonery
I think that one of the reasons that
Pirates of the Caribbean
the curse the Black Pearl remains one of
the more popular Pirates movies is it
was the most action-packed it had the
least amount of Captain Jack Sparrow
drama and I think that by adding this
element which again has ties to the
predator fanbase first of all it's got a
predator you're tying it in there as an
action film with a different setting
than the fans are used to expanding the
mythology it's not mocking either one of
these franchises I think it's a remix
and putting them both in a situation
that you haven't seen before I think it
is gonna get people interested and again
like as a die-hard fan I don't want to
see that franchise further drug through
the mud and and laughed at and made fun
of that's just not appealing to me as a
fan of that franchise I don't think that
fans are gonna feel the same about this
movie got it Spencer final thoughts look
people have seen every adults have seen
every iteration of diehard possible
let's cherry-pick the best parts let's
keep Bruce Willis update it and put in
front of a new audience and yes I think
it might be time to maybe have fun with
the concept of die hard in a way that
still has some seriousness to it the
zootopia's capable of die hard is a
movie about a
cop shooting his way through a situation
maybe it's time that Zootopia could
handle that in a fun cute way with
animals that would bring something new
to that you didn't even pitch a Pirates
of the Caribbean movie to me you pitched
an origin story for the gun from
predator 2 that happened to have some
pirates in it I think people are going
to be furious that Johnny Depp's not in
that movie or where Jack Sparrow went if
you can recast them and I think that
predator fans are going to be furious
that like it just strips away everything
that's good about a predator and I think
it's not fair to say that Preda that
Disney is going to make a r-rated
predator movie I did is just that that's
never gonna happen I disagree
BAM what a Smackdown Roth tell us about
the facts and figures that happened
there let's discuss the facts there has
been one pg-13 that I know of alien vs.
predator was rated pg-13 so there's that
you already said it Nick Wilde is the
name of the Fox Dan how does some
well-researched Canada wait really
in-depth about that one moment which I
got to say is pretty swing when it comes
to the argument you're both pitching
very tough tough movies to pitch I think
in total Spencer made the better case
for his film and why it would work for
across audiences that are fans of both
franchises plus he did do the impression
I think in total just the argument in
terms of why this film would work go
Spencer for me all right that's one for
Spencer Danielle alright I will say my
favorite comment from Twitter was
someone putting their own movie at
George Hef says the only answer is
chicken little versus aliens he sees a
xenomorph
no one believes him until it's too late
Chicken Little then has to lead a
resistance movement against the alien
incursion and that made me super happy
but going to the poll on YouTube I wish
I was kidding but so right now YouTube
goes with Spencer forty or fifty five
percent and Dan there take forty four
percent so Spencer wins this point boom
Spencer taking it dan good research on
that done
I wish I could go to an alternate
universe where these two movies are made
and you tell me which one is more
entertaining oh you know what I'm glad
we don't live in that hellscape just
wait 18 months oh yes when the merger
goes through you guys it's time for
round three it's a backwards fight mmm
holy crap all right man breaking out a
backwards fight on the first show back
okay gentlemen pick any character from a
comedy movie dan Wow
any comedy ever made any character from
a comedy movie them's the words that
just said I'm gonna go with a Ted
striker
from airplane the lead the pilot Ted
striker kids are gonna love her the hero
pilot from sucker brothers airplane
Spencer I'll go with Venkman original
Ghostbusters Bill Murray mm-hmm Bill
Murray's Venkman and the question which
movie character would make the best Jedi
Knight which movie character would make
the best Jedi Knight is it Ted striker
from airplane Bill Murray
from ghostbusters thank Men Dan your
first sure well the thing about Jedi
Knights is you have to be able to tap
into that inner power of yourself to
feel your surroundings and I feel like
Ted striker as a man has many demons as
we've seen many Jedi Knights do before
he famously has a drinking problem he
has he has also struggled with
attachment as many other Jedi Knights do
but he is also a man who's able to to
summon great powers things on that
airplane happen in a way that much like
Jedi powers shouldn't happen in the real
world people actually turned into jello
all sorts of things and I think that a
Jedi Knight really needs to be able to
overcome adversity and we've seen Ted
striker both on an airplane and a space
shuttle and airplane 2 the sequel has
been able to overcome great physic
and situational adversity to save many
many lives and and what is more to heart
and a core of a Jedi Knight than to save
the lives of the innocent there you go
opening salvo from Dan Spencer Thomas
what's at the core of a Jedi Knight is
being cool and calm and collected and no
one in comedy cinema is more cool and
calm collected than Bill Murray as
Venkman this is a guy that deals with
the supernatural in his day to day and
still has the wherewithal to crack jokes
to make light of the situation to not
panic
he's he's someone who's so balanced on
the inside that he can have a hand in
the real gritty world and in the world
of the force and you know the spiritual
dimension he's somebody who isn't ruled
by his passions he doesn't form
attachments whether it's his
relationships with women or in ships
with his friends or his job he's someone
who who kind of lets life come as it may
and he will make the best of any
situation he's free to improvise he has
a good moral sense at the end of the day
and he doesn't have a massive problem
with alcohol all right fight it out
fellas well if you were familiar with an
airplane you would know that Ted striker
himself does not have a massive problem
with alcohol a physical ailment versus a
chemical dependence secondly yes
absolutely Peter Venkman struggles with
attachment he practically the worst
thing about Anakin Skywalker was the
fact that he stalked Padme Amidala into
a fathering twins with him Peter Venkman
stalked Dana Barrett constantly he he
forced his way into her apartment the
guy is creepy he's exactly what Anakin
Skywalker was he's a guy who's thinking
with the wrong head he's gonna allow
himself to get clouded by love this is
not what Ted striker does as a matter of
fact he puts aside his conflicted
feelings for a lane an airplane and and
is able to land that plane and despite
being in a massive amount of
psychological trauma that's what you
need when you're a Jedi Knight you're
always conflicted but you need to put
that aside for the greater good I would
argue that that Venkman does not do that
he turns on the other Ghostbusters when
they're committed he says I don't know
who these guys are I think they're crazy
you need someone who's gonna be in the
trenches with you Ted strikers a is a
veteran he lost so many people over
macho Grande and
he still remains loyal to them and Peter
Venkman is loyal to no man and
particularly no ideology and I think
you'd make a terrible Jedi exactly you
don't want to be loyal to an ideology
the passions of the way to the dark side
Ted striker is a man haunted by war he's
someone who's aggressive who breaks out
into an aggressive flopsweat who slaps
people who who's so mentally unbalanced
that he broke his way onto that airplane
in the first place he Venkman is a man
of even temperament he he's a guy who is
experienced with beam weapons as we've
seen with the proton pack Venkman or
striker can't even land an airplane he's
crashed to three airplanes in his
lifetime
Jedi's usually need to be good pilots
Venkman is Zen like he's basically Yoda
with better sentence structure Peter
Venkman was the one that caused the most
damage with his proton weapon I don't
want him in charge of a lifesaver Ted
striker never slapped anyone that was
dr. rue Mac and he did not force his way
onto that plane he bought a first-class
ticket to Chicago smoking and I think
that again you were talking about a guy
who is absolutely ruled by his passions
he's a show-off he's an eager he's an
egomaniac this is not what you want in a
Jedi Knight but you wanted someone who's
in tune with the world around them who's
at least paying attention striker
manages to kill three innocent
passengers right next to him via his
monologuing and he doesn't even bat an
eye people are hanging themselves next
to him he's surrounded by death by pain
and he feels nothing he is not force
sensitive they change just like there
are lives that is not his fault I want
each of you to talk to me about
lightsaber skills
pure and simple lightsaber skills how
they'd handle one of those weapons in
battle Spencer yeah I mean like I said
beam weapons experience he's someone who
who's so comfortable with weaponry he at
he has little phrases of like you know
light him up don't cross the streams
he's basically a self-taught warrior
whereas a Ted strikers never handled
anything except a plane that he's
immediately run to the ground I would
say the Ted striker landed that plane
against all adversities didn't run into
the ground that plane would have crashed
if he'd not been in control of it don't
cross the streams is this full of
sweating people to guide him down it
took inflatable auto pilots it took all
this stuff he can't even handle a
Frank help me handle lights he was being
a sabotage by Rex Kramer who wanted him
to crash the plane which is made
abundantly clear he landed in spite of
the sabotage II was getting afraid this
becoming a referendum on how many times
Dan seen airplane cuts I'm sorry that I
know my characters and yours better than
you do but that's not what I'm saying
here don't cross the streams it's not
Peter venkman's catch phrase that's
Egan's have to say and I guarantee you
that Ted striker as a military veteran
has had small arms training so I promise
you that he's been trained on how to
handle a weapon far more than Peter
bacon was his unlicensed nuclear
accelerator on his back has ever had who
would be the better teacher handing down
Jedi skills to another Jedi because that
often comes into play fellas Dan we've
seen that Peter Venkman is openly
resentful of a new generation of
Ghostbusters so he obviously would not
hand down his skills to a new generation
whereas Ted striker I think would very
much want to train a new generation of
pilots Spencer I disagree I think he be
very open to a new Padawan learner
especially if it were a comely female I
think he's very he's very nurturing and
instructive of the people who come into
his paranormal office and he's willing
to teach them his ways and I think that
wait so only if it's a female well yeah
yeah like yeah sadly Bank Minh is a bit
of a final thoughts Dan make this your
Tom with the young generation he was
literally shocking innocent young
college students for no damn good reason
he's a terrible teacher as a matter of
fact he was fired from a university he's
not gonna be a teacher Ted striker is a
man who's seen the worst that life can
throw at you he's overcome that
adversity he's been calm and collected
under pressure he has saved lives Peter
Venkman is all about himself he's
everything that a Jedi Knight should not
be and I don't want to put the fate of
the the galaxy in the hands of a man
who's going to not be there because he's
off chasing some skirt Spencer put a
cherry on your sundae yeah Ted striker
is not a man who's cool under pressure
Venkman is the epitome of calm and cool
and collected that's what it means a
Jedi Knight to me it's not necessarily
doing good or evil because we've seen
Jedi do good and evil things all the
time
Ted striker has Sethe written all over
him he's basically Anakin it's trauma
waiting to be exploited by the first
Darth Maul too bad his eyes Adam there
you have it man what a weird battle that
was Ross what do we got valiantly fought
on everyone's part because I could think
we can agree neither of them would make
good Jedi I have to say Dan man he
really did know both characters fighting
out and I think just made the stronger
argument for why he's unsuitable Jedi
would be the more suitable Jedi yeah I
was like Dan had an IMDB app man boom
all right that's 104 Dan Danielle talk
to us a lot of folks were super bummed
at Axel Foley didn't get mentioned
Beverly Hills Cop myself included put a
banana in his x-wing butt so according
to the YouTube poll as of right now
we've got Ted striker at 72 and minke
minute at 27 no way Dan takes the point
Wow and the score stands going into the
speed round two one dan the man Merle
all right you guys should read watch
airplane Yeah right okay before we go to
the speed round I just want to thank our
friends at t-mobile for hooking us up
and all the good stuff Thank You
t-mobile and yeah we appreciate the good
times uh you guys speed round time so we
had three questions the winner of the
movie fights is the first one to get
four answers right this is a
best-of-seven so we have four speed
round questions first one to four wins
for answers awarded to them is our
victor okay there are four speed round
questions right now it stands at two one
Dan and they each get twenty seconds to
answer the first one to answer goes
first 20 seconds and then they each get
a ten second rebuttal you guys have been
here before
oh yes oh yeah new coat of paint all
right
let's play some speed round let's do it
question one all right the last Jedi
hits theaters tonight and we are pumped
what director who has not yet been asked
to do a Star Wars film should get to do
one James Gunn let's go with sir
let's go Chris Nolan Wow all right
Christopher Nolan vs. James Gunn Spencer
you answered first 20 seconds on the
clock for you James Gunn is a great
visual storyteller we've seen with the
Guardians movies that he's very adept at
sci-fi he can mix humor he can make
great characters that are memorable so
I'd love to see these archetypes in his
hands because he's created his own
iconic science fiction characters what
can he do in the Star Wars universe he's
somebody who who has a good heart and
compassion for the people in his films
that still have that big spectacle going
on and you need everything to work in a
Star Wars movie you need to work as an
archetypical Joseph Campbell style
storytelling and you need to work as far
as things you've never seen before
guardians 1 & 2 delivered both of those
and I think that if you give him start
with time all right
okay we've seen what James Gunn's Star
Wars movies look like they're called
guardians of galaxy 1 & 2 Christopher
Nolan is a guy who with all of his
movies no matter what you think of them
he knows how to do a theatrical
experience and I think as more and more
Star Wars movies come out and they be
come out every year you need to entice
people to go see a Star Wars movie in a
theater I think that Chris Nolan is
going to take Star Wars and turn it into
a theatrical experience second to none
you take his sensibilities his sense of
scope you add in these beloved time all
right 10 second rebuttal Star Wars is
about heart and feeling and compassion
and warmth and I get none of those
things from Chris Nolan he's a visual
master but I think his characters
usually fall short of the standard of
Star Wars which is all about humanists
and celebrating each other and I think
that your of time I think that you have
Chris Nolan in conjunction with some
great creative minds that could perhaps
fill in any store
he hasn't again with James Gunn he's
already worked in the system he's
already made space opera and I think the
guardians movies are great we don't need
Star Wars to just be another guardians
let him continue Wow whoo coming out
slogging Roth another tough one but I
gotta say that Dan made a pretty strong
point about James Gunn essentially
having already done what you may do with
the Guardians so I would have to get a
point down point for Dan conferring with
my esteemed colleague Danielle okay so
for these ones I'm as I'm sure that all
of you have figured out for the speed
rounds we're not gonna be doing polls I
am still looking at your comments and
there have been some really really funny
ones a lot of UDL mojo Toro was one that
came up that I thought would be a really
interesting pick a couple of that
someone wanted it to be a Big Lebowski
remake that is also fine for me I do on
this one I gotta agree with Roth I
really liked the points that she made I
as much as I love Star Wars
star-lord he is basically just like a
more modern Han Solo yeah
there you have it two for Dan my vote is
moot Dan you get the point right there
it is three one Merle going into
question two of the speed round and here
it is oh listen all y'all it's the
sabotage round beastie boys reference
for those of you scoring moment each
player will hear the question and will
get to pick their opponents answer for
them which they must fight in honor of
disaster artist what is the best movie
starring James Franco your highness
okay so Spencer will be arguing for your
highness
Spencer what do you got Ford in both
howl howl all right so we have howl and
your highness
okay Spencer you're going first for your
highness the fantasy genre is one that's
rich with tropes ripe for lampooning and
you get a great performances out of
James Franco and out of eastbound and
down they they send up these things you
got Natalie Portman to do a slapstick
comedy that's amazing you never see her
in roles like that Dan how many movies
we've seen about JD Salinger finally we
get one about The Beat Generation about
Allen Ginsberg and and it's it's not
some stupid stone it's the worst like
it's bad for James Franco to be in a
stoner comedy that's the bad James
Franco stoner comedy that's a reason you
don't see Natalie Portman in roles like
that it wasted all that potential what a
director coming up pineapple Express
that movie should have been great it was
almost impossible to sit through all
right rebuttal I'll take stoner
half-assed James Franco over completely
failing and falling on his face arthouse
pretension James Franco I think he bit
off way more than he can chew and he was
exposed as kind of a sham that he's
still to this day building back I will
take James Franco taking a risk over
phoning it in James Franco doing the
18th version of the role that he's
played 17 times before how was
interesting it was not boring it was not
lowest-common-denominator
like your highness all right wow what a
battle and let me remind everybody that
this point is a must-win for Spencer
Gilbert a must win in this bitter grudge
match of real-life enemies just kidding
in this bitter grudge match of friends
Roth what are you thinking well Danny
McBride was the other star of your
highness
very difficult round very round so hard
both had Barker's and you did the best
you could with them but I feel like you
actually Dan made the argument for why
that movie was the more interesting
movie to watch esteemed colleague yeah
no I actually have to agree like I would
be I'm way more interested in I'm not
gonna see either of these I'm seeing the
one oh I'm not but I now I kind of want
to go see how like
I'm interested in seeing him as part of
The Beat Generation where as you know
that your highness is just a bunch of
more of the same so ya gotta agree that
being said Dan takes the point and Dan
you are our winner Wow
[Applause]
congratulations my men all records out
the window now this grudge match the
title was not on the line correct
there's like it was you think on Twitter
should the title be on the line should
we have a belt handing over ceremony
between Spencer and Dan or not I wonder
what they'll say Dan tell us where they
can find you and tell us about something
exciting you've coming up I really hope
that how was actually about Allen
Ginsberg I was about 70% on that yes I'm
glad no it's just want to say like it's
so much fun to be doing this show again
with you guys and this team and I'm
looking forward to taking the show I
hope watching at home let us know what
you thought we'll be back in 2018 but I
just I feel like we have a chance to
really have fun here again and and take
out some of the you know this is a
debate show and we're having fun but I
want to try to take out some of the like
over-the-top negativity that I think at
times we we indulged in a little too
much and this has just been I think we
can still have fun and argue with each
other and a really interesting fun way I
love Spencer I love debating this guy he
knows how to push my buttons which makes
it even more fun and this has been a
really good time and I and I hope people
enjoyed this and they'll come back next
year and when we bring it back full time
well said my friend Spencer thoughts
super glad to be back I had fun the new
format I hope you guys had fun watching
it I'm excited for our judges that you
guys did amazing I think this was cool
that it's a consensus and Dan you'll be
judging future fights here and there
yeah so yeah we're taking a break now
because we need a break we can be
vacation but tell us what you think and
there's time for input but I'm happy
with it you guys like it there's good
times heck yeah super good times
Roth this was such a great time it was
Allen Ginsberg
have not seen it maybe well now I don't
know one thing that we can all agree on
is that Logan was the best comic book
movie of the year
yeah anyway that's what I think but look
you guys this is meant to be fun you
guys are great debaters it's interesting
to hear your point of views particularly
when you're having to argue things that
you don't necessarily fully believe it
so I enjoyed watching you and I hope you
guys did too
Danielle yep cosign this was super fun
and just one last thing from the chat
I'm Spencer they're all very happy you
get to go poop now thank God for that
Rothen spent Danielle thank you for
holding it down dan and Spencer awesome
fighting I mean like you said it was fun
to fight this guy cuz he knows how to
press your buttons it's fun to sit back
and watch you too cuz yeah the only two
people to ever hold the movie fights
championship belt but it's the dawning
of a new era thank you for joining us in
this new era this has been a blast it's
been so much fun to stand right here and
direct traffic a little bit and yeah
thanks for tuning in and we'll see you
next time
bye now this episode was brought to you
by t-mobile switch to America's best
unlimited network
you